good afternoon everybody my name is
Daniel pol I'm a scientist here at the
New York stem-cell foundation and I'm
going to talk to you today about a
platform that we've been developing here
over the past few years using automation
to perform stem cell research so the
title of today's talk is toward large
scale functional genomic studies through
the use of automation of induced
pluripotent stem cells expansion in that
differentiation so for those of you that
don't know us the new york stem cell
foundation has been around a little over
a decade now and the major aim of our
foundation is to accelerate the kids
accelerate cures for the major diseases
of our time through stem cell research
and we've been able to do that in three
different ways so we set out to
establish ourselves within the global
scientific community by not only
providing funding and so we do that to
innovators such as fellows and
postdoctoral investigators and the our
efforts for those are open throughout
the year as well as our outreach and so
we host a conference every year as well
as symposia throughout the year but
what's different than most foundations
is that we have a Research Institute and
so here at the research institute we
have - these focus teams working on
areas such as neurodegeneration diabetes
and orthopedics but what I'm going to
talk to you about today as well as our
robotics until we have a big robotic
platform as well as a scaled stem cell
by a bank that's available to the wider
community as well next let's being able
to fund people all over the world so
wherever you are in the world and that
you're looking for funding do feel free
to go onto our website and take a look
at the the RFA that are live we've been
able to like I said fun people really
across the globe I'm a little over a
couple of years ago now we move down to
a brand new facility and so we are now
in central Manhattan in a fully
dedicated Research Institute where we
have all the facilities that we need to
be able to do to perform stem cell
research at the foundation we focus on a
number of different disease areas so
things like bone regeneration diabetes
heart disease and a whole spectrum of
different neural disorders from autism
Alzheimer's Parkinson's
msyn schizophrenia and we've had a
pretty strong publication record as well
over the past ten years we've been able
to put out papers covering everything
from prevention of transmitting
mitochondrial disease modeling
Alzheimer's as well as working the
neural area on Parkinson's disease and
and generation of protocols such as
those for deriving microglia as I said
though the reason why I'm speaking today
is because of the the platform that
we've been able to build over the past
few years I think when IPS cells first
came to came came to be known it was
pretty quickly realized that they'd be
an excellent model for obviously
modeling human human disease and so when
you look at how human disease is sort of
looked at especially in the modern age
quite difficult at sing glances and well
then we're looking at genomes and we're
trying to make genomic and medical
interpretations from from the genetics
eventually that leads back then to the
diagnosis or the treatment of a
particular condition and this has been
great and so jeeva studies have been
tremendously beneficial in in
elucidating the roles of different
genetic variation to endpoint phenotypes
and so an example here you know this
could be any particular Manhattan plot
but this one here is the type 2 diabetes
and you can see here a whole range of
different genes that are associated with
the onset of type 2 diabetes and it's
great there's a whole bunch of genes
here that are well known to be
associated with sort of pathways
involved in in insulin and metabolism
and things like that
however it also elucidates different
genes to date we still don't really know
that function or the role and the role
of these polymorphisms within the onset
of these diseases and yet to get to this
point it's taken many thousands of
samples and thousands of people to to
analyze these datasets and get us to a
point where we have an understanding but
we don't yet have a complete picture and
so perhaps using stem cell technology we
can improve this understanding this is a
paradigm that probably many people
listening are familiar with where we've
taken skin biopsies or even blood and
you can reprogram these cells back into
induced pluripotent stem cells grow them
in culture and then you can turn those
into really any cell type you like so
long as you have a good enough protocol
once you
that cell type you can then obviously
begin to screen candidate drugs to
identify things that could go back into
the clinic obviously we also tied
together then genetics as well and using
things like CRISPR we can make isogenic
controls and we can do lots of advanced
now science just in the dish however and
for many of you I'm sure you're familiar
it takes an awful lot of work to be able
to do this kind of work it takes a lot
of hours in a tissue culture hood it's
hard to work with large numbers of cell
lines typically just because of the
quite intense culturing conditions that
stem cells require and so we set out to
to really try and understand how would
we be able to get to the same point as
genetic studies where they're using
thousands of people but be able to do
that with with biological samples
without yourselves and so one of the
questions that we sort of started out
with its sample size
you know what scale should we be using
IPS derived models to really accurately
improve our biological understanding but
that introduces a whole question on its
own and that is at what scale can we use
these IPS es without really hitting any
technical barriers and so if you look at
the hurdles that are involved in IPS II
work they are quite numerous so you can
have all sorts of variation variation
that stems from from the donor itself so
the sex of the person their ethnicity
the age at which you collect them and
obviously their health status things
within the samples themselves once
you've been able to say derive even a
somatic cell or than an IPS cell it will
depend on how you reprogram those cells
how you're growing them which media
you're using which basement matrix and
obviously things like growth rates of
the cell lines as well there's obviously
a lot of technical variation that come
in from just doing routine science
consistency in your passing passages are
you using similar split ratios every
passage are you consistently plating the
same number of cells are you just doing
things the same day every day most
likely because I feel a scientist using
doing cell culture in a hood I know that
this often doesn't happen then finally
right at the end of this it's great
having the cells and great being up to
differentiate the cells but what if
ultimately then your readout is
inconsistent and you don't have a robust
readout that that's occurring the same
way every time even in your control
samples
and so what we wanted to do would get to
a point where we could sort of enable
power basically how do you bring power
to these studies and how do you mitigate
the hurdles that we've just described
well here are the New York Center
foundation we decided to establish
something called the global stem cell
array here we've got an end to end
process that we've been able to develop
in-house for the collection of piece
donor samples so everything from skin
biopsies or blood samples through to the
endpoint distribution of those samples
so we've got to been able to collect
samples with consent forms and IRB
approved protocols and we can do this
across multiple sites we then bring
those starting samples into the lab and
we can now with our robotics be able to
produce IPS cells from them
differentiate them and use them perform
genome editing as well
we've got really stripped SOPs and we've
got a great little system here and those
samples then become banked so that they
can be distributed to researchers and so
for both academic and commercial
applications we were able to distribute
those cell lines to the wider scientific
community and one of the questions is
why did we switch to automation why did
we use this from from the beginning well
I think when you start looking at how to
how to make a stem cell line if you
think about it just as a process it
seems pretty simple
you know you take a biopsy you maybe
perform some some assays on the cells
that you're deriving from the biopsy but
you can start to establish a small
fibroblast Bank from there you can grow
those fibroblasts reprogram them into
stem cells and then grow those stem
cells up and begin performing
experiments on them like I said in
theory that seems very simple interest
for a small number of samples it's
totally practical but when you start
thinking about how to do large panels
and large batches of cell lines and you
break down each and every step you
actually begin to realize that how many
steps there are and when you're trying
to juggle many of these things in
parallel it either requires a very large
number of people to be able to do this
or alternative solutions and so for us
we switch to automation and so now
you'll see sort of in this video exactly
how we're able to do that
so this video will illustrate the nice F
global stem cell array that we use for
our IPS production here you can see our
the automated incubators that we have
the system here operates on the
quarantine conditions for the initial
somatic cell isolation the systems can
passage the cells feed them we have the
automated images as you just saw that
contract the fibroblast growth we next
move on to a cluster of three systems
that performs the cell flowing the
subsequent growth pathogen and then
reprogramming process and we can then
cherry-pick an array cell lines in 96 or
plates I'll talk a little bit later
about some of the systems that we have
for separating stem cells from non
reprogram cells and finally once we have
finished the Republic reprogramming
process we can then move on to arrange
the cell lines in 96-well plates I
continued their expansion passes them
into eby's for continued QC analysis at
the VP's and then we can freeze the
cells back down in in matrix tubes or
within plates for the subsequent
experimentation later in the process
and so a couple of years ago now we were
able to publish this in major methods
describing the development of this
system obviously since then we've gone
on to to make a number of developments
and I'll talk about some of those in a
moment but this was the basic underlying
principle of what we had done as you saw
in the video
those entire processes just being able
to automate each of those individual
steps as being was enormous e
time-consuming and required a lot of
backwards and forwards between engineers
and scientists and I think one of the
powers of the foundation now has been
bringing those different disciplines
together scientists certainly think
slightly differently to maybe the way
engineers do and be able to bring those
groups of people together and be able to
produce something like this platform's
being a tremendous success here when you
look at the actual data that came out of
the other publication I'm not going to
go through everything now and feel free
to to go and look at the the manuscript
but we're able to see ultimately at the
end of it that we did see quite a
significant reduction in the variation
in in terms of differentiation that we
were seeing in cell lines that were
produced under automation versus those
that had been manually derived or colony
picked and things like that and so
ultimately what was what we what we
think we see as the progression of this
sort of system is is the development of
of these end user sites so obviously
setting up a big facility to just
produce IPs else well we realize that
not everywhere is going to need to do
that there only needs to be the
continual production of so many lines
but the distribution and then use of
those lines that that has to happen and
so how do people in their own labs be
able to handle lots of cell lines in
parallel and so we're starting to see
the upswing of the use of Robotics
within laboratories and we really see
that end-user sites will soon start
being able to do with in ways that will
be accessible these sorts of experiments
on large numbers of cell lines within
their own labs or perhaps core
facilities so since producing the
automated platform like I said it's gone
through a number of steps of refinement
and improvement over the past few years
has been a particular focus on blood
reprogramming just
roll increasing the throughput and we
spent a lot of time building a lot of
software back-end we found that in
building sort of this custom platform a
lot of the out-of-the-box solutions for
limbed systems just weren't really
applicable and weren't able to fit into
what we wanted to do here so we bought
in-house the software team when we've
developed a pretty comprehensive
software system is the back end to all
of this in addition as crisp as things
like crisper cast 9 have continued to
rise in popularity wanting to build out
a way to perform genomic modifications
at scales has been something we've spent
a lot of time working on and so the idea
of being able to transact either lots of
different lines or the same line with
lots of different guide RNAs and then
derive stable either isogenic or knock
out cell lines and now something we're
able to do using again the robot the
robotics that we have here with that
said it does illustrate though where
although having the robots makes things
a lot easier there's still a lot of
hurdles to overcome so if you think
about something like one a clone
realization where we want to produce to
say a single cell line that's come from
a single cell which is critical when
doing isogenic Corrections and we're
able to plate ourselves into into
96-well plates and see the outgrowth of
colonies so after about two weeks you
see this this wonderful colony here
that's looking pretty pretty nice and
we're able to go back in time and start
to see it may be a little hard to see
but it's sort of within the center of
your screen where the colony came from
and if we go back to day 1 and 0 and
you're going to struggle here I
appreciate that and back to Daisy row
finding the original cell that it came
from can be a real challenge is there
one cell there are there two cells there
in this particular picture the cells
actually right in the middle even though
it might be difficult to see on your
screens and so you know this is a very
tough problem to solve
especially when you have lots of wells
to look through in lots of plates and
different different cell lines and so
one of the things we spend a lot of time
more recently doing is trying to use
machine learning and AI approaches to
see if we can identify track the
colonies using these machine learning
algorithms
as well as go back to the single cell
and how these identify single cells and
so use these convolutional neural
networks we've been able to do that to
come some some success some quite good
success actually be able to identify
colonies in a they're very busy very
dirty images it can still successfully
identify them all the way down to things
like the single cell and so as we get to
there we want to start thinking beyond
reprogramming and putting the cells to
use outside of just having made some
cell lines or corrected some cell lines
what else do you want to be able to use
with them I think one of the things that
we started to see as we began to use
ourselves in differentiation protocols
was whether we could use machine
learning to guide and optimize the use
of differentiation protocols one of the
things we've seen here is that there you
know there's a wide variety of different
protocols if any of you have gone out to
sort of started differentiation it can
be a little bit a case of well where do
I start
because there are so many different
people saying that there are all these
different ways of producing the CN cell
type that you might want what we've seen
though is that a lot of these protocols
tend to overfit to the cell line with
which they were created so it could be
that they were tested on one or five or
maybe ten cell lines but as soon as you
start expanding that beyond the
protocols can start to fall apart a
little bit the cells just behave very
differently so once once you expand your
donor pool and so trying to solve this
problem has been something we've been
doing it to some degree and ideally then
this would speed up the discovery of the
ideal differentiation protocol and you
could really hone in on what you want
from the beginning and so the paradigm
we've been using to do this has been to
sort of use design of experiment
approaches so putting the cells into
into a raise of samples and then
performing the automated differentiation
of these looking at the results having
good optimize data readouts that we can
rely on an area like I said able to be
reproduced time and time again plug that
data back into a software or an
algorithm look at what it's saying next
to do and then perform those
modifications eventually you go back to
the beginning and you keep going round
and round until you come up with the
ultimate optimized differentiation
protocol I'm rather than having cut
done on one cell line or three cell line
we're doing this on batches of 24 48 96
cell lines at the time to be able to to
really optimize this as quickly as we
can
and so now we've been able to platform a
number of different protocols onto the
on to the robotics and do this
reproducibly and so we're really getting
to this point now where we can take
disease and control cohorts put them
into the same plates or across multiple
different plates generate this kind of
cell types who wants to get readouts
from and then be able to analyze the
cellular phenotype at the end of it
ultimately now we're able to train and
then test different models with on these
cells and so it allows us to take
protocols that have been generated in
the lab as well as those that have come
in externally and do this across
multiple cell lines so we've been able
to platform things like views of
glutamatergic and GABAergic neurons onto
the platform using both small molecule
and nd n2 driven approaches and now
beginning to optimize more and more of
the oligodendrocyte the microglia and
certainly the organoid work that we're
seeing more and more up in the field and
so this platform we really think sets us
up to be able to perform research at a
very large scale we have a number of
active collaborations where we've
produced both cell lines for
collaborators as well as then
differentiating and producing the
material that will ultimately go into
large RNA sequencing experiments I'm so
we're quite excited about where this
platform's headed if you want to reach
out for any more information please do
feel free to do so and so finally this
brings me to acknowledging all the folks
that have helped make this platform
possible I stand I talk in front of you
today is really just one member of a
giant team of people that have helped to
bring this together and the focus list
adhere really only represent a snapshot
in time of an enormous number of people
that over the years helped contribute to
the development of this platform we're
very proud of what we've developed here
and quite excited about what it what it
holds for the future of stem cell
research and so that's it for me today
and I look forward to answering your
questions by email right now